She would hit me up on Instagram
to come out after the show.
She was with five girlfriends.
I just show up,
and they all have tattoos,
and they're talking about
the bartender's micro-penis.
I was like,
"Yeah, that sucks for him,
like this little dick guy."
You know what I mean.
Girls, if you wanna know
if a guy has a ...
what kind of dick a guy has,
insult a guy with a small dick
in front of him
and see how angry he gets.
We'll make for sure
we're testing Andrew by that.
It's the same thing
with vaginas.
When I dated a guy who referred
to a girl he dated as having ...
one of her labias were longer
than the other
so he called Stroke Pussy.
The worst person.
It's to me,
kind of joking about it.
Did you get angry?
Not at him, I was just like,
"Ha ha ha ha ha.
I'm never showing you mine,"
which I eventually
definitely did.
Yeah, she taught him.
At least mine has a stroke
on both sides.
So you got mad because they were
making fun of your penis.
I was like, "How dare you say
about us.
We are good people.
We're good people.
We'll go down on you.
We'll finger you.
We'll love you."
Did they take you to a strip bar
'cause that's all of Portland.
That is all of Portland.
I never went to ...
No, I didn't go to one.
But, no, they ended up
going into a photo booth
and taking pictures
of their own tits
and giving it to me,
as like, "Here."
Like as an appreciation.
I think I probably could have-
That's like the ... in Hawaii
when you get like a lei.
That's what they do
in Portland.
They go into a photo booth,
they shove their tits up-
Of their tattooed tits.
Everyone has tattoos there.
It's very earth-toned.
How do you feel about that?
I like it. I don't know,
sometimes ...
Or, at least,
I used to look at
when someone would have
a ton of tattoos as dirty.
I'd be like,
"Oh no, they probably
have all the STDs."
That would go through my head.
But now, since I have them all,
I'm like,
"Yeah, these are pretty cool."
It was pretty cool.
Maybe I'll get a tattoo now.
I know guys that only wanna
date girls with tattoos.
Yeah, that's 'cause
their mom had tattoos.
-No.
-Yes.
My mom thing doesn't
really check out there.
No, that was the best
when I go my mom has COPD.
She has emphysema.
You're like, "You wanna date
someone like your mom."
I was like,
"Yeah, like a scuba diver."
Some of us sleep apnea
Someone that also has a tank.
I have to explain.
Yeah, your mom has a tank.
People don't know that people
with emphysema have tanks.
Oh, really.
Yeah, you have to like bridge
that jump.
Yeah, my mom
has really bad emphysema.
Okay. So your joke ...
I'm helping him
write a joke 'cause he ...
I was like, "Every dates ...
Men always go after their moms."
So his mom has emphysema
so he should say that,
'So, my mom has an oxygen ...."
You have to say
she has an oxygen tank,
and then go to the scuba.
Yes, my mom has an oxygen tank.
She's always on oxygen.
She has a tank
with a tube.
Right. So I've been dating
a lot of scuba divers.
I'm like,
"Can you wear it to dinner?"
That is great. That's great.
The problem is
they're never on land.
Yeah. Yeah.
Come on. Come out and look.
You gotta look at another
fucking reef, really.
All of his dates have
to happen in the ocean
just so these women
can remind him of his mom.
That's great.
I like tattoos on guys
when they don't ...
when they're mistakes.
When they're like, "Yeah,
I got this when I was 18.
It means nothing.
It literally means nothing.
I don't know why I got it.
My buddy ...."
I like bad stories
with tattoos.
Not intentionally bad
where they're like,
"It's a joke we got."
But like, truly it meant
something to them at one time
and now it's so humiliating.
It's like wearing a TBT
on you constantly,
a reminder of
when you were lame,
and you weren't cool.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I like that, but I don't like
fresh tattoos with new meanings.
Or if somebody ...
Yeah, I told you about the guy
I went out that had
the broccoli tattoo.
Yeah, that's pretty gross.
Actually, I'll take that back.
Adam Levine last night
at the Superbowl, I dug his-
I love it. Sleeves.
Does he have sleeves?
I dug everything.
I know everyone
was so not into that,
but Adam Levine is so hot.
But what about if you
have sleeves and stuff,
and then you're an accountant.
I feel like there's
a lot of people in Brooklyn
that are like,
"Oh, I'm tattoo arm rugged ...."
It says something about who are.
Oh, my God.
For sure.
Look at Adam Levine.
Wow.
I mean, California,
across the stomach.
He's got a lot of tattos
Some guy did a name ...
some like, fat guy
in the Midwest
just did one and wrote Illinois
across his and took a ...
It's been going around.
What about Bieber?
Bieber is covered now.
To me, it just says you probably
would have cut in another world.
Like, it's a form of cutting.
I know that a lot of people
get tattoos for the pain of it,
that's why it'd be
appealing to me.
I think I would like
the pain of it.
Some people get off on that.
I think that's why a lot of
people can't stop getting them.
But also,
there's gotta be case studies
about people that get tattoos
and mentally how different
they are than people
who choose not to.
I don't know.
I got my ...
What's the closest
to a tattoo thing you've done?
You have to do
something rebellious.
I used to pick really, a lot
of certain parts of my skin,
or pull hair out,
like a OCD, pain thing.
Okay. You had trichotillomania.
A tiny bit, yeah.
Oh, wow.
For short periods of time
when I was a kid.
A lot of people do.
Not trichotillomania so much
as pressing pressure points
and hurting my skin.
It had to be ...
I've never talked about this.
Here, here,
until it would almost bleed,
or chewing parts of my mouth,
and then I'd stop.
It was always ...
Sometimes I'll get
into that again.
So many people do that.
I mean, the more that I have
female friendships in adult life
and we're getting further away
from the stuff we did as teens,
like more of it's coming out.
Woman are becoming more
comfortable talking about like,
"Yeah, I picked out
all of my hair when I was 17."
Or, they're currently doing it.
A lot of people
have these things ...
I don't think the picking
out your hair is as ...
People can be more open about
eating disorders than that,
at this point.
But I hear you.
I know a lot of you
are out there.
It's never been my thing,
but it could've been my thing.
I don't judge that at all,
but that is a thing
that girls do a lot.
I only cut once after
I got caught shoplifting.
I was just like so mad at myself
and I wanted to punish myself.
I understood cutting
in that moment.
So that to me, I get it.
But tattoos, yeah.
I've just never had anything
that I just care enough about.
You know, I think
that's the classic thing,
that reason people give that
they don't get tattoos.
But I got my nose pierced
when I was 18.
Oh, really.
Yeah.
Septum. No, side.
Side because I knew-
How long did you keep it in?
I researched it and I knew
that ...
I have enough acne scars
there that it would just ...
the worst,
it would look like an ...
It would just blend in,
so who cares.
It's not gonna be a ...
I knew that there was an out.
I really liked the Ankh symbol,
the Egyptian Ankh symbol,
which kind of looks like a
female symbol when I was 14-18.
Thank God
I didn't get it tattooed
because I wanted
a big one on my ankle,
but I also sort of thought ...
I was judgemental about tattoos
so I never did it.
Yeah, I think its-
And I'm glad.
I got this pierced ...
like the top of my ear.
I thought that was
really rebellious.
That is so-
Does that hurt?
And then it got infected.
I thought how I felt horribly
that it was connected to my ear.
And then my dad was like,
"Yeah, you're right."
I think he was just saying
that because he didn't-
What do you mean it's connected?
What are you talking about?
It's connected to your ear.
Like, so it got
a little infected
and then I didn't feel healthy.
So then I connected-
Andrew T. sleeps in logic
in his stories
'cause he's gone there,
but you ...
He doesn't walk you
to where he's going.
Do you mean that you got
the flu or something,
and or an ear infection?
Yeah, I just was feeling off.
Oh, like an ear canal infection.
I don't now. It was infected
on the top of my ear.
And then I started to feel sick.
He's a hypochondriac.
Oh, you're body.
But then I connected it
to the ear,
but it was probably
just I had the sniffles.
You know what I mean?
You're right.
But then when I told my dad,
who's a doctor, he was like,
"Yeah, you're probably right."
I think he didn't want
the freaking ear ring.
He didn't want his son
to have an earring
on the top of his ear.
Yeah.
There's a joke there too,
somewhere.
What?
Nikki can help you develop it.
No, no, no.
I think.
He's got it.
I like it.
Am I here. I think I'm here.